marriage the or-or-or wedding did you
have just the two of us hotel room in
Malibu yeah just the two of you in a
hotel room in malmö yeah wouldn't you
need someone to like perform right
through there Richards now then we went
back to Stockholm and get all the papers
signed and everything so what's happened
in the family theater no Bruce Princeton
no Springsteen not let the Steven know
the Richards nobody was there
what kind of a question is that what
happened in the hotel
Wow you you uh you've been in the e
street band for so long how has that
changed throughout the years well this
first few years you know you just have a
fun you know I mean you're not thinking
about the business or making it or not
making it you just you love the fact
that you're playing you do what you want
to do you know and that's why I'm very
very conscious of trying to help create
a new infrastructure to support new
bands now because it's a big problem now
as far as it was for us to make it much
much harder now but when when you first
made it like when you've been a part of
the river and hungry heart and that sort
of very successful and world-famous
music re it's not the granted success
forever is that sort of laurels that you
can rest on no no I mean we growing up
when we did in the era area I call the
Renaissance you know which is the 60s I
mean you had very high standards okay
there you grew up with the Beatles and
Rolling Stones and Dave Clark Five and
the WHO and the kinks and and so we'll
never meet those standards as far as I'm
concerned will never be as good as the
wrong excelence you know so you keep
trying and and the river was a huge
success for us it was the three million
records which we thought was the most
records you could sell you know we're
super playing to sold-out arenas
everywhere we'd made it you know now the
next record sold 20 million which you
can't figure on you know but you can't
you also can't count that because that's
not real something's going on it's not
quite real you know you know but you
also had tough times after that well
yeah I mean I don't know if he called
tough times exactly but I became on that
river tour which is our first tour of
Europe I became a kid came up to me and
asked why I was putting missiles in his
country in Germany and I was like
looking at my guitar case it's a guitar
it's not a missile what are you talking
about
and basically decided to dedicate that
the eight most three eighties for
politics and just discovering all the
bad guys we were supporting and try and
do something about it you know so that
became a tough time only because being
political in those days was not cool
yeah
so we did a very big thing with South
Africa thing called Sun City and brought
down a South African government and you
know he started he started succeeding on
that level and people get afraid of you
a little bit so I backed off you know
I'd said what I wanted to say and
basically I didn't work for seven years
after that but it was kind of how to
work how does that work literally walk
my dog with seven years and and then
David Chase call you know creator of the
problems yeah he saw me doing the
induction ceremony of the rascals the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and the first
time was they were televised and I did a
little comedy kind of thing and he said
let's get him for the TV show it's this
new TV show yeah so I'm the rest is
history for the viewers yeah yeah
actually you're gonna be play a gangster
again yes yes I'm gonna be doing a TV
show here in Norway it's about a
gangster playing a gangster again that
goes into witness protection
and he had been watching the Olympics at
Lillehammer fell in love with went
through that fix and decided to go into
witness protection in Norway
yeah it's going to be on this very
Network you know these the this Kevlar
Network as it's called they're doing in
Norwegian television series yeah
incredible yeah welcome yeah thank you
please welcome little Steven